a federal judge rebuked special counsel
robert muller and springs Paul Manafort
from life in the clink hide your kids
hide your wife Paul Manafort will be out
of prison within about two years as
Muller goes down at court wages go up
for the first time in over a decade amid
all the non traverses we zoom out and
consider what the Trump legacy might
look like twenty years down the road
then International Women's Day sparks
the Communist revolution in Russia and
kids go on strike to protest climate
change do you have to produce something
to go on strike I will find we will
analyze all of it I'm Michael Knowles
this is the Michael NOLA
[Music]
updates from Russia gate oh it's taking
a tough turn for Democrats this has been
you know I forget what it was a few
weeks ago we had a really tough week for
conservatives and we're all kind of down
and then this past two weeks three weeks
maybe the the green New Deal then you
get alon omar spouting anti-jewish slurs
then you get people defending alon omar
in the democrat party then you get
russia gate going down at court really
really bad sign for the special counsel
probe and for all the democrat alarmists
on russia we'll get to all of it but
first let's make a little honey let's
make a little honey money i've been
flying around a lot I was in Cincinnati
last night we'll talk about that speech
as well but first let's thank untuck it
have you ever wondered why traditional
button-up shirts look so long and baggy
because they were never meant to be worn
untucked but untucked shirts were
specifically designed to be worn
take a guess how do you think they were
meant to be worn the name is untuck it
take one guess untuck it is the brand
that you've been looking for it's the
original untucked shirt a modern
solution to an old problem with no
tucking or tailoring required no matter
your size or shape their shirts are the
perfect untucked length have you been
frustrated about that this happen to me
sometimes you want to wear your shirt
untucked so look sometimes you want to
look old tuck it in and be all formal
but a lot of the time especially these
days even at work you want to wear your
shirt untucked and you don't want look
like you're wearing a dress and I've
been a fan of untuck it since before
they advertised on the show jeremy
boring got me into untuck it because i
think he owns one of every single shirt
that they have the thing about untucked
shirts is one the cuts are really great
I went into a brick-and-mortar store and
they fitted me all out and got me the
perfect size but the quality of the
material is really really good so it's
not just this great cut you also get a
really really high-quality it's going to
be much nicer than most of the shirts in
your wardrobe try it on it in person at
one of untuck it's fifty stores or go to
untuck it com2 get started they even
offer free shipping and returns on all
orders in the US you can save 20% on
your first order by using my code MKS at
checkout 20% off your first order on
komm promo code M K s so we had the
sentencing of former Trump campaign
Chairman Paul Manafort that happened
yesterday you heard they were gonna
throw the book at him
Muller wrote up an 800 page report they
didn't want any leniency for him at all
they said this guy he's he's not working
with prosecutors the way we want him to
he should get 15 20 years maybe more in
prison
guess how much the judge gave him judge
TS Ellis gave him 47 months but that
includes the time he's already been in
prison so actually he's only gonna serve
another 38 months and that's not even
true because he's almost certainly gonna
get at six months early so he's gonna
get what 32 months he's gonna be out a
little over a year or a little over two
years two and a half years that is a
huge rebuke of Muller and that's what
this is really about the stakes here are
for the Russia investigation this judge
TS Ellis actually in a in a fairly
direct sense rebuked the Special Counsel
investigation here because he made a
point to acknowledge that this sentence
these crimes had nothing to do with the
Trump campaign in Russia this is a
humiliation for the Special Counsel this
is a humiliation for the Russia probe
man affort was the guy he was the one
who worked with the Russians for years
he was working with pro-russian forces
in Ukraine he was in when he was running
the Trump campaign he was talking to
people he must have had nefarious
dealings they went after him 800-page
report and they give him 47 months which
really becomes 32 months pathetic
oh absolutely pathetic so what what is
the point here what where does this come
from why was it so different than all of
the mainstream media expected this gets
to the importance of the judges because
this judge as the mainstream media are
going to tell you now was appointed by
Ronald Reagan in 1987 oh they are few
oh they wanted mana fort to rot never
see his kids again here is the reaction
from MSNBC it says this judge Ellis has
never read the first thing about Paul
Manafort had never known that Paul
Manafort was known as the leader of
something called the torturers Lobby for
representing unsavory dictators around
the world long before ever he ever came
to Donald Trump's orbit and you know
this wasn't just a one-off you know
brief period of crime here that he's
been accused and convicted of this was a
10-year crime spree as Muller as
prosecutors have laid out this was a
massive effort to defraud banks and
evade taxes for a long time and then to
lie and commit felonies after already
admitting guilt and making a deal with
prosecution so it's it's a really
surprising outcome from a federal judge
who you know from what I'm told by
prosecutors been in front of this court
tends to be a lot harder on poor
defendants than on white collar
offenders excuse me just once I'm sorry
I should have done it I just wanted to
make sure I could hear the whole clip oh
yeah that's nice you just get off an
airplane you're feeling a little
dehydrated luckily MSNBC provides all of
the waterworks that we want a crime
spree from Paul Manafort
what does Paul man affords crime is
crime is wearing tailored Italian suits
is what his crime is you spent too much
money on his suits the guy's a lobbyist
lobbyists work with crooked people
that's what he did is he a little bit
crooked yes obviously a crime spree are
you kidding me there so and then then
they just try to completely twist it
they say well he's really hard on poor
people he's for the judges probably a
racist too easier I know they cuz they
wanted to send him to the claim for
anything they're so desperate this is
the trouble you know last night I was
talking about global warming at the
University of Cincinnati and I made the
point if you're gonna predict the end of
the world if you are going to predict
the apocalypse you only get to do that
once you've got to be right when you
make these huge accusations when you
make these huge
predictions like Donald Trump committed
crimes with the Russian government to
steal the 2016 election his presidency
is illegitimate he needs to be in prison
when you make those kind of claims the
truth is going to come out at some point
when Al Gore says the world's gonna end
in 15 years when Oh Cassio Cortese says
the world's going to end in 12 years
that time is gonna come he said that the
polar icecaps could be melted by 2014
2014 came it seemed like it was so far
in the distance when Al Gore made that
movie in 2006 but then 2014 came around
what happened there was more ice mass in
the polar icecaps than there was in 2006
and then he became a laughingstock and
then no one saw his sequel and now
nobody listens to Al Gore even fewer
people listen to him now than listen to
him in 2006 that's the trouble with the
Russia claims they were so furious after
they lost the 2016 election they had to
blame it on somebody
so they blamed it on the Russians they
made up this huge story that has
distracted our politics for over two
years now they bet the farm on this
Russia conspiracy thing and it's just
not panning out and the worst that
you're getting is a longtime lobbyist
getting a slap on the wrist and he's got
to go to the clink for a couple years
it's a humiliation and what else in
Russia gate we found out today you
remember Trump's personal lawyer Michael
Cohen testified before Congress and
basically gave nothing no new
information just to testify the Trump is
a big Meany and a really bad guy
well now it's come out that Michael
Cohen met privately with the House
Intelligence Committee Chairman Democrat
Adam Schiff for 10 hours to prepare for
that testimony four separate occasions
ten hours of testimony Schiff who lives
in California represents a district in
California flew out to New York to meet
with Michael Cohen now you have to
wonder okay what what was he doing was
he I mean obviously he was coaching the
witness this is not good
that's not a good look for Democrats why
did they do that because they knew it
was gonna come up empty and apparently
Adams ships not a very good coach
because 10 hours of coaching later
Michael Cohen still looks like a schmuck
on Capitol Hill still doesn't give you
anything so desperate so now now they're
launching investigations into the
finances and the business and this and
that it just looks so desperate because
that the clock ran out for them they
said okay we're gonna this Russia thing
we're gonna go as hard as we can with
Russia
you can't go forever eventually people
need you to put up or shut up you have
to produce results and now they've got
nothing now the dog ate their homework
and it's a beautiful sight to behold
Michael Cohen we know he lied to
Congress he was convicted of lying to
Congress he's the first convicted liar
to Congress to be called back to testify
before Congress and we know he lied
there again we know that he lied about
not wanting a job in the White House
it's a matter of public record he sought
a job in the White House we know that he
lied about not seeking a pardon he did
seek a pardon matter of public record
they just end up with egg on their face
being rebuked and reprimanded by a
federal judge who has a good sense of
justice here by the way I hope Paul
Manafort still gets pardoned not because
what he did wasn't wrong of course it
was wrong he's a lobbyist lobbyists tend
to work with pretty crooked institutions
and do kind of crooked things but do you
does anyone really believe Paul Manafort
would be in prison right now if he had
not committed the real crime of helping
Donald Trump become president that's the
crime that's what they knew that that
was what he was being investigated was
being prosecuted for and and this judge
I think in a very fair way actually
carrying forth justice said we're not
gonna throw away the rest of this guy's
life because you don't like that he
helped a Republican win the White House
some other good news for conservatives
the economy doing very well actually
there's some bad news couched in a lot
of good news the bad news is we only
added 20,000 jobs in February but job
growth basically flatlines this way
below expectations
now February is a slow month probably
this is just a weird fluke and I say
that I don't say that to try to brush a
bad jobs number to the rug it's just
that right now we currently have a
record number of people employed so this
is I think the 18th record that we've
hit during the Trump presidency
we've got 157 million people in this
country employed that's an all-time
record so you can't really say well
they've only added 20,000 jobs well ok I
mean our unemployment rate is basically
zero where I think the unemployment rate
is about three point eight percent which
is about as low as you can possibly get
it labor force participation way up
sixty three point two percent during the
Obama years he would always try to cook
the unemployment numbers by hiding
relatively low labor force participation
but here it's relatively high so this is
really good economic news and and this
is true across the board so unemployment
rates for adult women teens blacks and
Asians stayed about the same all near
historic lows and unemployment for adult
men whites and especially Hispanics
dropped pretty precipitously in February
and and so you've got really tight
employment regardless of what the job
growth number is you've got really tight
employment what does that mean
wages are finally rising for the first
time basically in my life it's been a
long time since since real wages have
risen for people we've got three point
four percent wage growth year over a
year this is really good news for the
American worker who hasn't really had a
raise in 10-15 years first time in a
long time and so you see those two
competing narratives obviously you're
not going to hear that on MSNBC or CNN
you're not going to hear the good
economic indicators they're gonna focus
on Donald Trump's tweets about know
collusion they're not going to talk
about all those boring statistics of how
a record number of Americans have jobs
unemployment across the board for every
demographic is in near record lows
you're not going to hear that but what
what is the Trump legacy going to be
this is sort of what I was thinking
about is I'm getting this two opposite
information you know Russia Russia
Russia illegitimate Rama and you say oh
everything's going great it reminds me
history changes very quickly currently
the entire news cycle is Russia stormy
Daniels pornstars
total nonsense but history and
historical views of presidents change
very quickly when I was a kid Bill
Clinton was actually impeached for lying
under oath for taking his intern into
the Oval Office and making her into a
human humidor and then humiliating her
before the entire world actually
impeached and then for the 15 years
after the Clinton administration he was
the most popular guy in the world
his popularity recovered so much all
people had were memories of that great
1990s economy all they had were memories
of the basically the economy that was
permitted by the Reagan administration
and then that you had this huge once in
a once in a 200 years tech explosion
with the internet and people loved
Clinton he was on the campaign trail all
the time for Democrats even some
Republicans wanted his endorsement now
think about the Reagan administration
during the Reagan administration you
heard of all these scandals the
iran-contra affair there were it was
just a completely made-up affair because
we were trying to fight communists in
Latin America oh no oh how terrible and
you they tried to make this into a big
issue they tried to take his presidency
down for it then there was a rumor you
know that Nancy Reagan was interested in
astrology they tried to make this a huge
story big headlines nobody remembers
that I mean nobody I think in the
Millennial Generation could explain to
you what the iran-contra scandal is how
many think about that if you're under 30
I'm in listening to this show could you
explain actually what the iran-contra
affair is I guess it's a reference
sometimes on TV news no it's nothing
it's nothing with regard to the Reagan
administration when we look back at the
Reagan administration we think booming
economy defeat the Soviet Union those
are
two things I mean the man has basically
been deified thirty years after he left
office or now I guess approaching 40
years out after he entered office and
he's become better and better and better
every year so what will it be for Donald
Trump is it gonna be Russia no the
Russia thing is nothing is it going to
be Paul Manafort did a deal with a
pro-russian Ukraine oh is it gonna be
stormy Daniels got it no nobody will
remember her name in like five years
that is gonna go away I think what the
legacy is going to be is the economy and
judges now who knows the economy could
tank that you could have anything but
happen if he has a second term then you
you could have obviously anything could
happen but just right now if this were
the Trump administration if you were
leaving office today what would that
legacy be the economy and the judges and
the judges are so important because you
look 1987 Ronald Reagan appoints judge
Ellis to the court say okay well who
cares about the judges because at
moments like this when real battles are
happening where real overreach is
happening like this Russia investigation
real constitutional questions are being
raised we have that rake and air a judge
to stand up for the Constitution to
stand up for law and to stand up for
justice and Donald Trump has filled the
courts with judges this is a pretty
pretty good thing what is the future
that look like for the right and the
left because you hear all this talk of
anti-semitism on the left you are all
this talk of nationalism on the right
and looking into the future
I think people have a sort of a bleak
view of it here here's Thomas Sol the
great economist Thomas Sol giving his
unfortunate view of socialism coming to
America the future of America I mean do
you think that we are destined to go
through a period of socialism a period
where these ideas that have not worked
no matter where they've been tried and
certainly wouldn't work here will be
tried here and
and could bring down our country well
the project the predictions of
economists do not encourage me to go far
in that direction but I do have a great
fear that in the long run we may on we
may not make it and I hate to say that
but and then one thing that keeps me
from being despairing is is of course we
don't know there's so many things we
can't possibly know and so we may make
it but I wouldn't I wouldn't bet on it
Thomas soul wouldn't bet on it very
intelligent guy very good observer of
culture and politics obviously great
economist economics is a dismal science
and I'm reminded though of John Maynard
Keynes another great economist who said
in the long run we're all dead so what
what Thomas soul is seeing is that
America is careening toward socialism
that may well be true it certainly was
careening toward socialism in the 60s
and 70s and then Reagan came in and
changed all of that now it seems to be
careening towards socialism again can we
stop at now President Trump says America
will never be a socialist nation the way
I'm seeing the future though is that the
right and the left are beginning to look
a lot more in America like they do in
Europe we're told this is a very
terrible thing oh no no American right
right wing is totally different way
better than the European right wing
they're not comparable at all and the
American left wing used to be very
different than the European left wing
now we're seeing a little bit more
similarity what is the European left
wing it's anti-semitic and socialist
that's it you can describe it in two
categories and in you're seeing that
turn with the new fresh faces of
Congress you're seeing them say no to
the party leadership they said this is
the direction that we want to go in we
don't like Israel we don't really like
the Jews that much and we love socialism
okay that's a lot and the American right
a little bit is heading in that european
direction of embracing nationalism of
saying listen we like our country we
like our culture
we want to talk a little bit more about
our country in our culture and securing
our borders and not just saying that
anybody can come in whenever they want
do whatever they want we're gonna focus
a little bit more on the nation and the
nation-state the Westphalian system that
has governed the world for 400 years now
president Trump has made this point
pretty clear he was it before he was
getting on an airplane today to go look
at the crisis in Alabama he called out
the Democrats as they are in typical
trumpian no uncertain terms
I thought yesterday's vote by the house
was disgraceful because it's become the
Democrats have become an anti-israel
party they've become an anti Jewish
party true that's true
and strany could say you could take it
even further and say they've become the
European left but I'm not sure that this
is a terrible thing I mean it's
obviously I don't want socialism and I
don't hate Jews so I don't like but I
don't like the left either so you know
where are we but I don't think it's such
a terrible thing that clearer
distinctions are being made because I
think when people say whether the
European form of politics in the
American form of politics are totally
different they're incomparable they have
nothing to do with one another that's
obviously ridiculous we come from Europe
our country comes from Europe our laws
come from Europe our political
philosophy comes from Europe our culture
comes from Europe our religion comes
from the religion that built Europe
that's where our ideas come from and so
it's not surprising that our politics
might have some similarity to European
politics as well maybe there was a
divergence for a period after the war
the Second World War where Europe was so
decimated America was unchallenged in
the West that there might have been some
divergence the sort of liberal consensus
the American hegemony throughout all of
all of the West but those days were
obviously numbered at a certain point
though the West is going to rebuild
Europe is going to rebuild and things
are going to
just certainly after the fall of the
Soviet Union those those two superpowers
dividing the world up amongst them
change then there was American hegemony
there is the American superpower now you
have other powers rising as well and
those old eternal political questions
come back
I think the future looks not it doesn't
look exactly like our past but by
looking at our past we can learn about
our future this is the trouble in the
United States where we don't study
history people don't study history they
don't study history in elementary school
middle school high school they don't
study it in college what they study is
ideology and that's a very poor
substitute and if people want to see
where the politics is going it would
probably be who them to look into our
history to look into our past
unfortunately though today the left is
so busy trying to erase our past censor
our past knock down statues turn away
murals turn away depictions that they're
not they're not going to be able to
learn very much and which is where you
get childish idiocy and activism such as
the global climate strike which is being
led by actual children and the left
believes this is a very beautiful and
profound thing we'll get to that we'll
also obviously get to International
Women's Day one of the worst days in the
history of the world not because I look
I love women you know I love women but
International Women's Day is just a
communist contrivance that destroyed
Russia and much of the 20th century
we'll explain how but first go to daily
wired.com ten bucks a month $100 for an
annual membership you get me you get the
Andrew Klavan show you get the Ben
Shapiro show you get to ask questions in
the mailbag you get to it get the what
Matt Walsh oh you get to ask questions
backstage you get another Kingdom and
you get 47 months for Paul mana for
Valon oh oh that's good
get your tumblr so that you can store
your 47 months supply of leftist tears
go to daily wire calm we'll be right
back with a lot more
the global climate strike so there was a
story that came out set your calendars
March 15th all the kids are going on
strike this was the headline quote
adults won't take climate change
seriously so we the youth are forced to
go on strike March 15 global climate
strike inspired by a 15 year old Swedish
girl who would cut class once a week and
called it a strike for global warming
and now there's going to be a big day
where all the kids do this I see a
couple problems with all the kids going
on strike the first is that kids don't
produce anything kids all they do is
consume at school they consume knowledge
at home they consume food they consume
clothing they consume money they get so
if they go on strike I don't know that
anyone's gonna complain I don't think
anybody is going to be harmed by the
kids going on strike I don't think that
it's it's going to mess up anybody's day
or anybody's schedule the other problem
that I see is that kids being kids can
be grounded so so if they all cut class
their parents can ground them the
parents can actually strike the kids I
don't mean physically they can I guess
they can do that too I mean they can
strike that they can prevent the kids
from doing activities they can prevent
them from going out with their friends
they can prevent them from you know
going to the movies on Friday night they
can prevent them from using their cell
phones and they can prevent them from
striking because they are kids and they
have parents so I don't think the strike
is gonna go very well but I love the
language of it I don't really mean to
beat up on these kids I mean to beat up
on the Democrat Party which is just as
childish they write quote we the youth
of America are fed up with decades of
inaction on climate change on Friday
March 15th young people like us across
the United States will strike from
school ok all right
breaking news teenagers cut class okay
fine
the the story goes on for decades the
fossil fuel industry has pumped
greenhouse gas emissions into our
atmosphere this is not true that's not
true for decades you have pumped
greenhouse gasses into our atmosphere
for decades I have pumped greenhouse
gases into our atmosphere the fossil
fuel industry is not an evil gangster
cabal the fossil fuel industry gives us
a product that we all buy and want and
need for our lives they don't they don't
put the gas into your car and then drive
your car around they don't know you do
that you're the wondering I mean this is
the problem with climate change that
they want to put the villany off on
somebody else they say oh it's the man
it's it's the wicked capitalist who's
polluting or it no you're doing it
you're do you like your cell phone well
you're got a mine cobalt you got to get
make plastics yuvan those plastics
aren't gonna break down and then when
you throw out your cell phone after two
years it's gonna end up in the Pacific
Ocean because of you because you want it
do you like your cheap consumer goods
from China do you're like your cheap
electronic goods do you like getting
around you like having heating during
the winter
do you like air conditioning during the
summer because you are the one releasing
all of that carbon emission by the way
the world isn't going to end in 12 years
it's not I'll bet every single penny
that I have to my name that the world
doesn't end in 12 years please someone
take me up on that bet nobody seriously
even believes it all they want to do is
hate someone else all they want to do is
blame someone else for their problems
which aren't even real problems you see
this even beyond climate change we talk
about our society talk about our history
there's always the mean terrible guy
though Big Daddy the patriarchy this is
somewhat know it's you you you have a
say you have free will you are in this
society you don't have Alexandria Cassio
Cortez
taking a thousand Ebers during her
campaign flying across the country 66
times for a congressional race where you
are in a district you don't need to fly
even once spending 30 grand on car ride
services spending 25 grand on flights
and then complaining because of the
polluters you're the polluters stop
flying or stop complaining about a fake
problem they did they it's all this
fantasy and it's all this shirking
responsibility and it's everybody's
fault except for my own and it's in the
macedonians stole the election and the
Russians stole the election and James
Comey said it's everybody's fault except
Hillary Clinton that she lost the is
everybody's fault except for you and
it's a it's pathetic but I think it is
endemic to the the leftist at leftist
activism these days and I I like to
bring up the kids because this is what
kids do the kids you know they've got
the they're reaching into the cookie jar
they're reaching into the leftist tears
cookie jar and they've got their hand in
there and a mom comes in the room say
what Michael do you have your hand no no
no uh someone made me do it no right no
I don't have no okay that's how children
behave okay sort of cute or at least
understandable when children do it but
now we have an entire political party
doing them now we have half of the
country doing it we have presidential
candidates doing it take some
responsibility stop behaving like
children I can't imagine that that's
gonna play very well in 2020 but then
the story goes on the kids say quote the
alarming symptoms of climate denialism a
serious condition affecting the whole
ways of government in the general
population mark our current historical
crossroads of make-it-or-break-it
action on climate change apparently the
kids never learned not to mix metaphors
their English class maybe they should
walk out of English class and there's
not not doing I don't mean to make fun
of their writing but it's not good
writing and I'll defend them in the
sense that I don't think Alexandria
Ocasio Cortes could put together a more
coherent sentence listen to what they
say the alarming symptoms of climate
denialism
so what they mean by denialism first of
all they're comparing normal people to
Holocaust deniers but they're saying if
you don't believe that the world is
going to end in 12 years you are a
denialist and you have a symptom it's a
symptom of a psychological condition
called climate denialism you're not in
your right mind this is not you are
insane you are a lunatic if you don't
think that the world is going to end in
12 years that's the symptom they're
talking in psychological terms because
our culture is so materialistic these
days it's so scientistic that we can
only talk about our minds and our souls
in physical terms so we say oh different
chemicals are firing off different
neurons are firing when we fall in love
or feel joy or feel fear and that's what
they're saying here then they say it's a
serious condition how do you cure the
condition for force I suppose it's just
agitating for socialism that's all it is
now it's it's noteworthy by the way that
these socialists because that's all it
is the green New Deal is just socialism
it is noteworthy that these socialists
always go after kids and women they
always go after the international you
the international union of students was
put up by the Soviet Union the World
Federation of democratic youth put up by
the Soviet Union they're always going
after kids and women and and nowhere is
this more apparent than today on March
8th on International Women's Day the
Google Doodle today for International
Women's Day was that little you know the
women's sign I think a lot of women in
this country think that International
Women's Day is about women but it's not
International Women's Day is the launch
of communism in the West Google Doodle
Today International Women's Day they
don't have a hammer and sickle on the
Google Doodle The New York Times says
quote International Women's Day isn't
going anywhere what's the history I
don't know they don't say NBC says
International Women's Day 2019 history
theme and importance what is the history
theme and importance the day is
simply a celebration it's a call to
action for everyone to continue to push
for complete gender equality okay but
what's the history what's it about okay
they say the early of 20th century was a
time when women were becoming more
active in their protests against
oppression and gender equality leading
marches and campaigns to demand equal
rights according to the official
International Women's Day website during
the International Conference of working
women in 1910 Clara Zetkin of Germany's
Social Democratic Party proposed that a
day be set aside every year across the
world to celebrate women and reinforce
their demands that's half true but that
misses the whole point because it
actually didn't start in 1910 the first
International Women's Day started a year
before that in 1909 and it didn't start
because of the Social Democratic Party
it started because of the Socialist
Party and the Communist Party's the
first one ever was held in New York 1909
organized by the Socialist Party of
America then in 1910 the international
socialist Women's Conference created
International Women's Day so okay that's
the first two years of it fast-forward
seven years you've got the the October
Revolution in 1917 happens after the
October Revolution Vladimir Lenin made
International Women's Day a national
holiday in the Soviet Union's when the
first things he did why why did he
prioritize this day so much he
prioritized it because on International
Women's Day March 8th 1917 an
International Women's Day a
demonstration actually started the
Russian Revolution this is the you can
blame International Women's Day for
killing 100 million people in the 20th
century I wish it weren't true but it is
just a communist contrivance whenever
you hear things with international and
it usually you're talking about
communist contrivance 'as the the
protest started because women textile
workers who were in Petrograd decided
that they were going to have a
demonstration this had been whipped up
by communist agitators Leon Trotsky knew
about this
and Trotsky said of the demonstration
quote meetings and actions were foreseen
but we did not imagine that this woman's
day would inaugurate the revolution so
they planned some meetings some
demonstrations this thing kicked off the
whole revolution this International
Women's Day was celebrated almost
exclusively by communist countries and
socialist activists until 1975 when the
UN adopted it so you know not much of a
change exactly and now to prove Thomas
Sol's point unfortunately it seems that
as America is becoming more socialistic
more left-wing they're adopting this day
- it's a terrible day we need a National
Women's Day I'd take a National Women's
Day celebrate American women that's very
good
but International Women's Day just like
all of these internationalist schemes
they're trying to divvy up all of
society along certain demographic lines
class lines gender lines racial lines
whatever women of the world unite
workers of the world unite and break
down national boundaries we shouldn't do
that we should have National Women's Day
I don't know what day that would be I
guess it could be Abigail Adams this
birthday or something we'll have to
think about this this is very important
all of this sort of navel-gazing which
is what you see on International Women's
Day obviously they hide the communist
origins of it they try now to just
celebrate it as girl power look at me
look at how great we are captain
Marvel's really a great movie it's only
sexism that is having all of the male
and female reviewers say that it's
terrible it's a it's a sucess this is a
culture of just celebrating yourself all
the time this is a culture that has
pride parades this is a culture that is
insistent on that sort of thing there
was a really negative outcome of that
sort of culture and it's like it's a
funny headline but I do feel bad for the
guy a billionaire named a hoot or EI
Lonnie Otto died this week during penis
enlargement surgery at the age of 65 in
a posh Paris clinic people
giggle at the headline is really the man
died this is a billionaire you got all
the money in the world you die on a
penis enlargement surgery his friends
say that he was always obsessed with his
appearance he was I guess he wasn't that
tall yeah obviously he had some other
physical issues that he was dealing with
and he was insecure about these things
he would have his accountant read out
his bank account statement multiple
times a day man has all the money in the
world could live a very long life and he
dies because of this sort of frivolous
surgery there's an important lesson here
for a perverse culture you know when
scripture talks about how the rich will
be made to look like fools the proud
will be made to look like fools folly
folly all is folly those are not just
empty words you can see that happen in
something like this you can see it it
even broadening the sense of just self
gratification and constantly meeting
self gratification
you've got the owner of the New England
Patriots guy has everything in the world
and he says well I think I'm willing to
risk it all for a $50 rub-and-tug
massage at a parlor in Jupiter Florida
it goes into a sketchy massage parlor to
throw away all of this this is very I
mean it is funny in a very dark way it's
it's funny that that the heart of man is
so perverse that you could have
everything billions of dollars
winningest football team in all of
history and be willing to throw it all
away for nothing for some cosmetic
surgery or for a rough lower body
massage at a massage parlor in Jupiter
Florida that is funny in a very dark way
but there is a real affect to that and
it reminds me that joy has to always be
closely guarded you know we're it we're
in Lent now we're in Lenten Lenten
period where Christians traditionally
fast they abstain from meat they're
contemplating their mortality on Ash
Wednesday the priest puts ashes
your forehead and says remember man that
thou art dust and unto dust thou shalt
return you think about these things and
you try to take stock of of this life
and this mortality heroes you only have
so much time in this world and you want
to make the most of it you realize that
you're you behaved badly very often you
do want to minimize that you feel sorry
for that you you regret that you confess
those sins you you really take stock and
you have hopefully a sense of humility
this Lenten period is a great anok is a
great antidote rather for pride doesn't
mean we need false modesty false modesty
is just another form of pride but true
humility does away with false modesty
and when you think of stories like this
you think gosh I'm billionaire he's got
everything in though he's a diamond
billionaire so he made his billions in
really valuable diamonds and he's got
everything yachts girls this that and he
throws it all away for some little
insecurity for some little pride some
guy owns the New York Worthy owns the
New England Patriots throws it all away
for just a little a little more
gratification if it could happen to them
it can happen to you it can happen to me
you've got to really guard that you've
really you've really got a guard
something that anxiety tom is soul feels
this country is going to throw itself
away for socialism you've got to really
guard that precious thing that we've got
you've got a really cherish it really
really protect it that's our show this
is nice to have a Friday show today I
got to get out of here because we're
running late as usual but I will see you
all on Monday in the meantime I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Noel's show
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Robert Sterling executive producer
Jeremy more senior producer Jonathan hey
our supervising producer is Mathis
clever and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Danny D'Amico
audio is mixed by Dylan case hair and
makeup is by Jessa
all Vera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Michael Noel's show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19